les états unis secouée depuis plusieurs
semaines par le scandale des prêtres
pédophiles en réunion extraordinaire à
dallas les évêques et cardinaux
américains ont fait d'un pape
impensable il ya encore quelques années
en votant l'interdiction d'exercer en
cas de déviance sexuelle mais pour
autant ils n'ont pas été jusqu'à
demander que ces hommes d'église soit
systématiquement défroqué jean marc loos
239 pour 13 contre nos aucune abstention
un sens on adopte en ir à dallas une
charte pour la protection de l'enfance
des hiérarchies catholique américaine
espère rassurer 64 millions de fidèles
choqué par dix ans de laxisme en matière
d'actes pédophiles chez les prêtres
obstacle pour la première fois cette
semaine devant la conférence épiscopale
des anciennes victimes d'abus sexuels
avaient témoigné publiquement
trop longtemps les coupables avaient été
mutées discrètement désormais sans être
chassés de l'église
ils seront définitivement privé de leur
ministère mais comme le souligne la
presse américaine sans aux évêques
avaient couvert leurs subordonnés
pédophiles ils ne sont aujourd'hui visé
par aucune sanction et les associations
de victimes présentes à dallas ne
cachent pas leur scepticisme
la conférence épiscopale nous a fait des
promesses quant à savoir si elles sont
un progrès ce n'est qu'à la longue qu'on
verra les associations de victimes
réclament et coller aux responsables
impliqués démissionne et répondent
devant la justice
dallas ne pouvait le décider en droit
canon les évêques ne relève que du pape